[Music]  I'm here at the Ashley Rocca Hoodie  estuary it's home to a lot of rare and  endangered birds and it's a very special  place for our district the northern  Pegasus Bay by law recognizes its  importance and while everyone is still  able to enjoy its natural beauty there  are rules in place to protect this area  all visitors need to be careful of the  birds in their nesting areas you should  observe from a distance and leave them  undisturbed vehicles dogs horses and  land yachts are not allowed in the  estuary if walking pass to get to the  beach on a nearby stop Bank it's best to  keep your dog on its lead and let's  leave the airspace to the birds  so no flying microlights drones or model  aircraft above the estuary it's all  common sense let's take care of our  birds and their home we've all got a  part to play in preserving our beaches  and estuary find out more at Waunakee  DDG opt-ins ed board slash beaches  [Music]